why don't you tell us a little about
your upbringing on how you went to the
fbi
all right i was born in cuba actually uh
i lived under communism on the fidel
for about three years before we were
able to leave in 1961
and we came here we didn't speak uh a
word of english and
uh my power my father had a job in uh
new york
actually at three in order to get us you
know
that this was going to be a temporary
hold that we were going to go back
to cuba when this banana republic was
over well needless to say that banana
republic is still there
so we decided to stay in america
learn english and then i went on going
to a school up in washington heights
new york and then we moved to the bronx
where i went to a catholic school
and there's where i started playing
football and i had the opportunity to
get
several scholarships and went to the
university of richmond and it was there
where i saw the movie serpaco and i knew
that that moment in time
i wanted to be into law enforcement
um it was kind of like a cool guy no al
pacino long hair beard
had the pretty girl with the motorcycle
and an old sheep english dog to add to
that
so i said this is what i want to do but
unfortunately back in the 70s nobody was
hiring
and the fbi refused to return my call so
what happened in 1976 or so
or the end of 75 i was watching
univision
and i saw this uh american non-native
spanish-speaking fbi agent
saying they were looking for spanish
speakers in the bureau
so i called the bureau right away and i
said look you got me you got my
application
i'm ready to go i meet the bill they got
back to me and said well you're not a
an american citizen so i became an
american citizen which is one of the
most proud moments of my life
and then i told them i said now i have
it let's get this going and in 1980
i became a special agent of the fbi now
let me ask you this
right prior to that what were you doing
before you became a special agent
well because i couldn't land a job in
the police department i wound up working
in some colleges as director of testing
then i got involved actually got into
the police department at union county
prosecutor's office
but it was short-lived i was only there
about a year and then the fbi came
calling and
of course the rest is uh i have the
dream of my life job
i love it i love the fact that it is a
dream of your life job now
jack if i was in high school with you
who were you in high school were in 10th
grade 11th grade who who was jack
falcone
well at first jack
he's always a jovial guy you know i
break balls i
i i like hanging around with a bunch of
the guys have fun
i played sports uh i didn't have a
weight issue like i developed later in
my bureau career
so i i'm always an outgoing social
person
so i i was not a bully but i actually
protected those who bullet
you know that were bullied and uh um and
that was the kind of guy people kind of
gravitated to me because of my size
i was this big mama luke 6'4 back then i
was around 240 250
and you know it was uh some kind of guy
that people
gravitate to makes sense so you bullied
bullies is what you did
that is correct okay and that that
apparently didn't change for the rest of
your life you enjoyed bullying bullies
well yeah i guess yeah so you're right
interesting okay
so now you go you go into the fbi you
got your dream job you're excited about
it
at what point do you get some of these
assignments that leads you to working
with the mob how soon did you get a big
assignment
well keep in mind that hoover died in
the in 72.
so the bureau did not really mirror the
demographics in our society
so here i come in this kid who speaks
spanish fluently
the kid doesn't look like an fbi agent i
didn't look your typical guy or dressed
alike
i grew up in havana i was grew up in
washington heights and the bronx
so i had a little something with it and
right around that time the fbi got
involved in working narcotics
which was the early 80s so i was the
perfect guy here i am i speak spanish
fluently
i know the streets i'm able to i'm a
social person
so i immediately started working cases
that were involving narcotics
and that's kind of where i uh i found my
little niche
in the fbi and and okay so when that
did take place what was your first
project that you got in and when it
happened was it kind of like
you were a fiend saying i'm hooked i i
want to do more
i'm in love with like at what point did
you know your job as an fbi agent you
were hooked on saying
this is exactly what i thought it was
going to be you know it was immediately
i went up working in a long-term
national security case so i really
can't discuss it you know patrick and
and i apologize for that but it was
where
i was working on the cover i was living
on my own i had a fake
identification just the way that cloak
and dagger just that whole movement of
being an
undercover and fooling people to
believing
the person you're trying to portray it
was just so
uh enticing to me and it was became like
my adrenaline drug it was something that
i drew my high
my my this is what i want to do and i
just couldn't
wait to do it more and again because
there weren't that many people who spoke
the language like
i did i was a shoo-in so i just started
growing from one case to the other
each with each case i looked as a
challenge
and i enjoyed working with the men and
women in the fbi
uh so it was a perfect fit it was my
little niche
some guys are good maybe working
wiretaps other goods and surveillance
well undercover became my my home
so at what point after you became an fbi
agent 1980 did you get the call for
dealing going undercover with the mob
well how many years later
oh it was back the first time i got the
call was in the year 2000 2001
because again all my expertise was
working narcotics
either posing as a drug dealer a
transporter
a money launderer then i started doing
police corruption cases murder for hires
asian organizers so i was all over the
map i never worked traditional organized
crime
actually it was all new to me because uh
here i am you know with my language
skill
this was my little place to go so i
worked the russian case and one of the
agents in that russian case said
listen we are have a situation up in the
bronx we have a strip club
and that's being shaken down by some
albanians and some wise guy you're
interested
so i said well what do you want me to do
you know and he said
well we want you to go in there maybe do
some payoffs
and see where it takes us to but pretty
much take the albanians out
well i said yes it was the latter part
of my career and
next thing you know yes i paid off the
mob guys to keep the albanians away
and just things started happening and
growing before i knew it
i was driving the captain of the gambino
crime family around
that's how it got started got it